welcome everyone my name is kevin
mullins i'm the manager of
administration here at honda canada
manufacturing
before we begin it's important that we
pause to recognize the traditional
territory where we stand today
this morning we are joined by lynn dolan
who's the deputy warden for simcoe
county and she'll lead us in the land
acknowledgement
following lin the podium will be taken
by jean-marc leclerc the president and
ceo of honda canada thank you
hello bonjour anin
on behalf of the county of simcoe it is
an honor and privilege to take part in
today's event and deliver the land
acknowledgement
the county of simcoe acknowledges that
the land on which we gather today is the
traditional territory of the
anishinaabeg nation which includes the
ojibwe the adawa and the parawatani
nations collectively known as the three
fires confederacy
we also acknowledge that huron windat
who occupied these lands prior to the
middle of the 17th century
we embrace the enduring presence of the
indigenous peoples of this region
including the chippewa tri-council first
nations comprised of basile first nation
to the chippewas of rama and the
georgina island first nation
we would also like to recognize the
diverse metis and inuit communities
within our region
the county of simcoe is dedicated to
honoring indigenous history and culture
and committed to coming together to heal
create future prosperity respect and
understanding in all of our communities
thank you merci megwic
good morning everyone
on behalf of all honda associates i'm
honored today
to welcome the right honorable justin
trudeau prime minister of canada the
honorable doug ford premier of ontario
the honorable francois philippe
champagne
minister of innovation science and
industry canada
and the honorable vic fideli minister of
economic development job creation
and trade for ontario
i would also like to welcome all of you
who have joined us here in person at
hana canada manufacturing this morning
as well as those who are joining us
online
honda canada manufacturing
today is an important day for honda
canada and for the people of ontario
and canada
honda's canada hottest canadian
manufacturing story
began in 1986 when we became the first
japanese car company to build vehicles
here in canada
the hard work skill and determination of
our original team
and everyone who came after them is what
led to millions of safe reliable
canadian-built honda vehicles
being proudly parked in driveways across
the country it also established alison
ontario on a global stage as a leader in
manufacturing excellence
today we operate three award-winning
plants and employ more than four
thousand talented associates who are
among the very best in the industry
we also work closely with a national
network of dealer partners and hundreds
of suppliers from coast to coast who
remain committed to the honda dna
together we are focused on
continuous improvement in the respective
areas of business
to move the company forward
now just a short walk from here
our associates build the 2022 honda
civic
a vehicle recently named both canadian
car of the year and north american car
of the year
and for the last 24 years it has been
the top selling car in canada earning
countless awards here and around the
globe
behind me
our gifted team builds another
celebrated vehicle
the honda crv
a class leading crossover that is the
definition of safety
convenience and fuel economy
and i'm proud to tell you that later
this year the 2 millionth crv
will roll out of this plant
and around the same time honda will
reach the milestone
of having built the 10 millionth
vehicle in ontario
hcm is all about canadians
building cars for canadians and that
brings me to the reason why we are here
today
in partnership with the government of
canada
and the government of ontario we are
excited to announce our plan to invest a
total of 1.38 billion dollars over six
years to upgrade our manufacturing
plants which will pave the way for hcm
to play a pivotal role in honda's
electrified future
today's announcement brings our total
canadian facilities investment to more
than 6.5 billion dollars
and we deliver new innovative
technologies processes supply chain
enhancements as well as vehicle research
and development programs
these investments will strengthen our
position as a world-class manufacturer
while contributing to the success of
canadian suppliers that we rely on
for over three billion dollars of goods
and services
every year
and by modernizing our plants
for the future we are protecting
thousands of high quality well-paying
canadian jobs for years to come
honda emile jones
[Music]
objective
honda's overall fleet today emits the
lowest amount of greenhouse gas
emissions
amongst internal combustion engine
manufacturers in canada
this is a point of pride and a measure
of our leadership
in fact we recently announced a plan to
have battery electric and fuel cell
vehicles represent 100 percent of our
north american sales
by 2040
and the nearly 1.4 billion dollars
investment announced today is an
important step toward that goal
indeed
the critical work of retooling our plant
has already begun
hcm has been giving the important
designation of north american lead plant
for the all new 2023 crv hybrid
which will begin mass production in
early fall
our plan is to introduce hybrid power
trains to all our volume models as we
progress towards our intensified
electrification objectives
this is an important step
in reducing our greenhouse gas emissions
today and advancing honda's global
ambitions of realizing carbon neutrality
for our entire business including
products and operations by twenty fifty
finally i wanna recognize those who hold
the key to our success
our associates
they build great cars and trucks but
perhaps more importantly
they have built atm's reputation for
manufacturing excellence globally and
that led to the canadian investment
announced here today
and in closing i would like to once
again thanks
prime minister trudeau premier ford
minister xianpang
and minister fideli for their ongoing
support of honda
and the canadian automotive industry i
will now invite prime minister trudeau
to the podium to give his remarks thank
you
[Applause]
mercedes
i also want to
salute the extraordinary team of honda
associates here
who've been pushing excellence here in
alliston and
throughout the supply chain for many
many years uh it's great to be here in
alliston with premier ford uh for a big
announcement that's going to make a big
impact not just on people here
but on the canadian automotive industry
i'm also happy to be joined by minister
champang and minister fideli
as well as mp tony van bynen from nearby
as along with other local leaders
we're announcing great news today
that is going to secure thousands of
good middle-class jobs across southern
ontario
and build a strong sustainable economy
in february
canada added
337 000 jobs and we've now recovered 112
of the jobs lost with unemployment at
its lowest rate since before the
pandemic started
canada
is having one of the strongest economic
recoveries on record
but we need to make sure that that
recovery is sustainable
and it creates good jobs and indeed good
careers
into the future and that means
understanding where the world is going
and celebrating the fact that honda sees
that and sees canada and canadians as
essential partners in moving forward
that way
for decades the automotive sector has
helped canada's economy grow and
provided those good high paying jobs and
careers
it also has helped build strong
communities like right here in alliston
and around
now
as we build a cleaner future the
automotive sector is a key partner in
powering the way forward our auto
workers have the expertise and skills to
build low emission vehicles
and we're here to support them
today
we're pleased to partner with honda and
the government of ontario to upgrade
honda's alliston production lines so
that they can make hybrid electric
hybrid electric models of their cr-v
the federal government is making a 131.6
million dollar contribution as part of
honda canada's nearly 1.4 billion dollar
investment this will support thousands
of jobs here in honda at honda in
alliston
but thousands more jobs in the local
economy and across the canadian supply
chain it means clean affordable vehicles
for canadians but also
cleaner air for us all and for future
generations in our communities
we are continually demonstrating that we
get
how to position
canada and the canadian economy and
canadians as ready to benefit
from the cleaner economy
from the
lower carbon future that means yes
better outcomes cleaner air for our kids
and our communities but also better jobs
and economic growth in ways that benefit
us all
we're positioning canada as a leader in
low and zero emission vehicle
manufacturing and do so doing so we're
building that stronger cleaner future
for all it is now my pleasure to turn it
over to premier ford doug
[Applause]
well thank you very much and and good
morning everyone it's great to be here
uh at honda and i just want to thank all
your associates you do incredible job
had an opportunity to say hello to him
it's a privilege to be joined by prime
minister and minister champaign along
with minister fidelity along with a
couple local uh mpps mpp andrea kanjin
our great attorney general doug downey
and i want to give a shout out to mayor
dolan from veniceville as well i want to
thank john mark and all the exceptional
people here at honda canada for having
us and for
contributing uh the the contributions
they make every single day here in
ontario
friends our government has a plan for
growing a stronger economy an economy
that works for everyone it's a plan that
is training more people for jobs and
skilled trades and it's a plan that will
attract investment to create good jobs
in our auto and manufacturing sectors
it's a plan that's connecting resources
and industries in northern ontario to
the future of clean steel and electric
vehicles
and it's a plan that's building roads
bridges and highways
expanding subways and public transit
and constructing more homes
all for a growing ontario
our plan is to build ontario
as we know no province has a prouder
history of auto manufacturing than
ontario dating back over a hundred years
while all ontarians are rightly proud of
our automotive history
we should be even more excited by what
the future holds
and what's happening today is a major
part of that future
because today we're celebrating honda
canada's 1.4 billion dollar investment
to retool its allison assembly plant and
upgrade assembly lines
with matching support from ontario and
the federal government
which
are investing
131.6 million dollars each
these investments will ensure honda
canada builds its next generation models
like hybrids right here in ontario to be
sold right across north america
this means the cars of the future will
be built right here by ontario workers
using ontario resources
i want to thank honda for the tremendous
show of confidence in ontario and the
workers who make it all possible
this is truly incredible news for the
entire province
like i said earlier ontario is the
automotive manufacturing powerhouse in
north america the sector employs almost
a hundred thousand workers with even
more spin-off jobs across the province
with our driving prosperity plan
the number of goods
well well-paying jobs will only grow
we made a promise to transform our auto
sector
by harnessing and unleashing homegrown
innovation
building up ontario made supply chains
and leveraging our highly skilled
workforce to fill the jobs of tomorrow
as we do every region of ontario will
enjoy the economic benefits
of these game-changing investments
friends our province has come so far and
we can't afford to go back to politics
and know
instead your government is saying yes
yes to investing in our communities yes
to good jobs for workers and yes to
another hundred years of being north
american leaders in the auto
manufacturing friends let's say yes to a
better and brighter future
that the people of ontario deserve i
want to thank you and god bless the
people of ontario no now i'll pass it
over to minister champaign
[Applause]
good morning everyone it's uh
it's great uh to be here with you today
because we are basically retooling uh
for the future so that's a very exciting
moment for everyone bonjour tulmon hi
everyone thank you premier ford for the
gun introduction
thank you prime minister to be here this
morning and everyone who has joined us
uh here today for this important
announcement and that includes obviously
my colleague fideli with whom
we say we make things happen here in
ontario when we work together but i want
to acknowledge also the mayor
the warden the mp tony which is with us
and the number of mpps
colleagues let me first offer special
greetings to the more than 4 000 workers
of the honda plant here today because
it's thanks to the expertise their
talent and their know-how that we are
gathered here this morning and i want to
say thank you because we could not be
celebrating this great investment this
morning without your work and i really
want to applaud you for the work that
you've been doing it's really thanks to
people that are here this morning that
we can stand here and celebrate this
great announcement
as the prime minister said in the
premier this is great news for alliston
it is indeed great news for ontario but
it's also great news for the entire
canadian auto sector
and i also want to acknowledge publicly
and say a big thank you to jean-marc
jean-marc i want to acknowledge your
leadership and i can make a promise to
you i won't be calling you as often over
the weekend as i've done in the last six
months so you can say that to your
family because today we have achieved a
great milestones together and it's
thanks in great part to your leadership
colleagues
everyone have seen that the auto
manufacturing industry is a major part
of our national economy but also it's a
critical sector for the jobs of today
but also of tomorrow and the prime
minister highlighted this very fact and
as consumer demand evolves and we've
seen it across the country we can
already see that the auto sector is
undergoing a major transformation a
transformation towards cleaner and
greener vehicles and that's what you're
going to see here in alliston and this
is what you're going to see at this on
the plant which is an award-winning
plant within the under family
that's why we need to seize the moment
and this morning is really about seizing
that moment and that's why when i look
around here today i am convinced more
than ever that canada has the talent and
you've seen a number of people here on
the line the talent is here but also
that we have all the tool needed to be a
world leader in manufacturing the cars
of the future and be part of the green
industrial transformation that we're
seeing not only in canada but around the
world and today in my view is another
great example of what canadians can
accomplish when we work together and
certainly be a key part of that green
industrial transformation
exactly
with the production of some of the
cleanest cars on the market honda is a
good example how the environment and the
economy can work at an end and that
you've heard from our government and the
prime minister this morning is a great
example if people are wondering how can
the environment can work together with
with industrial
investment but this morning you're
seeing a great example
and as a matter of fact in addition to
contributing to canada greenhouse gas
reduction gold on those hybrid vehicle
production will help to secure thousands
of well-paying jobs right there in the
community of allison right there in
ontario
and we've seen it and by investing in
the transition of the auto industry we
know that these jobs are not on the year
for today or for the short term but they
are here for decades to come and that's
what's really important because this
morning retooling is for the future
securing jobs not only for today but for
decades to come and that will ensure as
well the long-term success of the o2
industry here in canada
and let me just say in closing my
friends to everyone here at the on the
plan and across ontario and canada
let's be ambitious
let's seize the moment and let's take
every opportunity like this morning to
make sure that we can create here in
canada a strong and sustainable economy
for the future of canada with that
ladies and gentlemen it's my pleasure to
introduce you to the minister of
economic development of ontario my dear
friend vic fideli thank you everyone
thank you
thank you minister champaign premier
ford prime minister trudeau and thank
you to jean-marc and the whole team at
honda for hosting us here today
it's great to be back here in alliston
home of honda's assembly plant for more
than 30 years we're proud to be here
with some of the thousands of incredible
people who come to work here every
single day since taking office one of
our government's top priorities has been
to attract game-changing investments to
the province and building up our otter
sector to create the cars of the future
today's exciting announcement is another
proof point of our commitment to the
future of ontario's automotive sector
which we announced last year in phase
two of driving prosperity our plan for
the future
ontario's automotive supply chain is
ready to build the hybrid and battery
electric vehicles of the future and
driving prosperity outlines our
commitment to help make that happen
the retooling here of the alliston plant
is another sign of the hybrid and ev
revolution taking hold in ontario
since taking office we've taken an all
of ontario approach to making
game-changing investments that support
our auto sector and communities with
deep roots in manufacturing and this
includes last month's once in a
generation 500 million dollar investment
towards defasco's green steel production
in hamilton
as well as many important investments
across the province's auto supply chain
through our 100 million dollar regional
development programs
and now we can proudly add honda
canada's retooling of its alliston plant
to that growing list of future forward
investments
in our auto sector and its workers this
nearly 1.4 billion dollar project with
the support of more than 131 million
dollars from the province of ontario and
the federal government will manufacture
the company's next generation models
including hybrid versions built in
ontario and sold across north america
it's a major turning point for honda and
for ontario and our government is proud
to play a leading role
from day one our government's plan has
been to unleash ontario
our economic potential to attract
investment by making the province an
attractive place to do business once
again
through our strong open for business
mandate we have taken decisive steps to
lower taxes reduce electricity costs and
cut red tape
and this has reduced the cost of doing
business in ontario by nearly seven
billion dollars a year each and every
year honda's investment demonstrates
that our plan is working and helps
secure ontario as the engine of canada's
economy as we reposition our auto sector
and broader supply chains in the global
shift to hybrid ev and ev battery
production
we're grateful to the whole team here at
honda for this investment you're making
in the economy of the future and to the
hard working people across ontario's
automotive sector
thank you very much and we'll ask the
prime minister to return to the podium
[Applause]
thank you prime minister um we have 20
minutes for questions
with a limit of one question
one follow-up per reporter if you can
identify your outlet and your name
before you ask your question we will go
to the first question
good morning megan fitzpatrick from cbc
news the first question is for you prime
minister and if you could answer in
french and english please couple
questions on ukraine yesterday president
zelinski made a very personal appeal
for canada to support him and his
country not just with words but with
actions we know he wants a no-fly zone
we know so far your government has
signaled
canada won't do that what do you think
the consequences of not doing a no-fly
zone would be are you prepared to live
with those consequences if i could throw
a second part in there
we've seen that he may be suggesting
president zielinski that he's willing to
sacrifice nato membership in order to
put an end to this war he's apparently
expressed that to eu leaders have you
heard that from president zolensky given
that canada sponsored ukraine's
membership what would you think of that
if indeed that's true
first of all we are all
continually
horrified by the
terrible images we're seeing coming out
of ukraine
vladimir putin's illegal and unjust war
must stop
it is a
terrible thing for the people of ukraine
it's also a terrible thing
for the world this attack on democracies
this attack on innocence this attack on
the very foundation of pillars uh that
make us successful and prosper
prosperous and peaceful around the world
so we will continue to stand up and
support ukraine with humanitarian
support with refugee support
but also with equipment
military equipment
and lethal
equipment as well
this is something that we've continually
done because
the ukrainians
are demonstrating an ability to push
back defend their land defend their
country defend their culture defend
their fellow citizens against this
illegal russian invasion we've
continually said we're ready to do more
and we're working every day to support
more but there are as you point out
large conversations going on around nato
and i will be
going next week to the nato's meeting in
brussels in brussels uh to further talk
about the decisions we take as an
alliance as to how to best support
ukraine and protect uh the lives
of people in ukraine and around the
world
refugees
second question for mr ford please
mr ford when you came into office you
took a number of steps that didn't
exactly encourage the adoption of
electric vehicles like
revoking the rebate that had been
offered to ontarians to purchase the
vehicle and at the time you said you
didn't want to subsidize millionaires
buying teslas but it's not just tesla's
anymore it's honda it's other
manufacturers that are getting into the
market so if you want to continue to
support jobs at plants like this you
presumably would want to create more
demand for electric vehicles in ontario
so what are you going to do to do that
will you bring the rebate back if not
why not and if you want what will you do
instead to create some incentives create
demands for for electric vehicles and mr
trudeau do you think ontario should
bring the rebate back
well first of all thanks for the
question and uh just to set the record
straight since we've been in office
uh electric vehicles have tripled in
sales
so i guess that was a good decision but
we're putting money back into electric
vehicles we're putting money back into
our minerals and we're able to open up
facilities in in the north they actually
manufacture the batteries the critical
minerals we'll be investing uh tens and
hundreds of millions of dollars up there
to make sure we have a feasible plan
that those batteries can be put into the
cars we're investing billions of dollars
into the auto sector that the the prior
government didn't do matter of fact the
auto sectors were leaving now we have
five strong auto companies right here in
ontario producing vehicles of the future
we're creating jobs of the future we
invested 500 million dollars
down at the fasco
electric arc furnaces they get rid of
the emissions so i think we're doing a
great job on on the environment and uh
emissions i'm going to take that as a no
on the rebate mr trudeau if you could
respond and then
we're going to continue to make sure
that auto
automakers
invest in the jobs of the future and in
the cars of the future across the
country we're happy to work with ontario
on this great announcement today
[Music]
i can say that we know that families are
pressured right now with rising costs of
living the
global inflation crisis
caused first by coming out of this
pandemic and second by this illegal war
that vladimir putin has launched in
ukraine is putting pressure on families
that's why governments need to
continually step up to support
hard-working families with things that
are going to reduce their costs and
that's why we are so
excited about the ten dollar a day child
care announcements we've made right
across the country where we're seeing
child care costs reduced already
for many many families across the
country and i can tell you
that the government of canada and the
government of ontario are working very
hard and very well together we hope to
have announcements to make soon
question
hi matthew bingley from global news uh
prime minister and premier ford if you
could both respond to this uh to follow
up on that child care question you you
talk about the fast
the importance of getting a deal done
march 31st the deadline is rapidly
approaching to make a deal you're both
in the same room what is it going to
take for you to
to find common ground on this and make a
deal
well the common ground that we've always
shared is a desire to see costs lower
for hard-working families across ontario
and indeed across the country
and do the things that are going to help
them get ahead
we know child care particularly coming
out of this pandemic where
the advocates like the federal liberal
government for a long time for child
care were joined by business leaders and
advocates across the country who
understood
in the pandemic just how
important quality early learning and
child care is
not just for families not just for kids
to have the right start
not just for moms to be able to rejoin
the workforce
but also for our economy to grow
so from that place of alignment and
agreement uh we're working very hard
and like i said we hope to have things
to announce very soon doug
well then thank you for that question
and we're very very close as the prime
minister said
our our teams are working together on a
daily basis and we'll have a
announcement very very soon but it's so
important to make sure that we have
affordable child care
for all families right across ontario
we've we've created an environment
to create 338 000 positions available
across the province and we want that
opportunity for for families to be able
to go out there have a great paying job
a job of the the future right here at on
honda or other locations that's what our
investments uh we're gonna focus on
uh premier if i could follow up with you
uh megan asked you about the incentives
for uh evs and getting people to drive
them you talked about how many more
people are are actually buying them
three times i think you said
there's there is still the demand to
actually charge these vehicles and
critics have really pointed out that
there just isn't
enough infrastructure out there to make
sure that vehicles like the ones that
will be built here
are actually able to run at a longer
distance when is your government going
to commit to expanding that
infrastructure well i'm glad you
answered you asked me that question
we're actually setting a record in
canada we're putting 148 billion dollars
into infrastructure we're building new
roads we're building new bridges we're
building the 413 the bradford bypass
would be instrumental to the people that
work
here in alliston we're actually leaving
this facility to to talk about
renovating
stevenson memorial hospital just down
the street we're building new schools so
we're a government that is that is
building we're also putting uh chargers
in every single on route uh right across
the province and as as the market
demands it uh
we'll continue putting the chargers uh
throughout ontario but uh we're all
about uh building the economy also
building broadband which is absolutely
critical across this province we're
we're putting 4.2 billion dollars
towards broadband again so we're a
government that believes in
infrastructure and will continue to be
building
next question
hi prime minister alison jones with the
canadian press i wanted to follow up on
megan's first question about ukraine if
a no-fly zone is off the table
will canada meet zelensky's other
demands such as sending more weapons to
ukraine and sanctioning everyone who
supports the putin regime
every single week we've announced more
specialized equipment more lethal aid
going
to ukraine
we
stepped up among
the early partners
with shipments of arms to ukraine but
even before that
we've been part of operation you're
leading an operation unifier which has
trained up 33 000
ukrainian military personnel over the
past number of years
that has contributed
to their ability to stand so strong
against
the russian invaders right now so canada
has been a friend we've continued to
deliver on equipment including highly
specialized equipment
for drones uh we're going to continue
to be there for uh for uh
uh president zielinski and for
ukrainians uh and uh we're gonna
continue to bring the voice of ukraine
and advocacy for more support for
ukraine to that nato's nato meeting next
week
and as well will canada send chartered
flights to those ukrainians who apply to
come to canada through the expedited
temporary visa process
as we know there is a huge need for
humanitarian support which includes
refugee support when i was in warsaw
last week i met with
wives and children who
were very worried about their husbands
left behind and i've heard from a lot of
ukrainians that
they don't want to go too far from
ukraine right now that's why many of
them are staying in poland but we have
put in place measures for anyone who
wants to come to canada and not
automatically permanently if they only
want to come until the war is over
we've given a two-year
special processing that will not just be
a tourist visa but allow them to live
and work and find some stability uh for
as long as the work the war could take
uh we are going to be opening
applications for that two-week
processing extremely soon and uh we will
respond to the demand if there is
sufficient demand uh it requires us to
to uh do more like sending airlift we
will look at that we're always ready to
do more we will do whatever we can to do
as much as we can to get as many
ukrainians to canada as quickly as
possible because canadians are eager to
help to support to do their part to
welcome families fleeing violence across
the country and we will make sure that
they're able to do that
hi prime minister heather butts with ctv
news i just want to ask you another
follow-up on ukraine in terms of
specifics and specific aid here today
u.s president joe biden is set to
announce a fresh round of military aid
for ukraine valued at a billion dollars
but so far canada has only given around
33 million dollars worth of military aid
to ukraine president zielinski was clear
yesterday in the house that he needs
more weapons so why hasn't canada given
more military aid to ukraine such as our
allies
we've actually stepped up like i said on
highly specialized equipment that was
the top ask during one of my
conversations with president zielinski
a couple of weeks ago for uh for the
the drones that they're using
we're going to continue
to get as much equipment as we have that
they can use
as possible
the challenging the challenging supply
lines getting things into ukraine are
an issue that all of nato is facing
right now but we're going to continue to
be there with as much help as we can
possibly give because ukrainians are not
just fighting heroically to protect
ukraine they're also standing up for the
values that we all
uh fight and
and respect and uh underpin our our
societies and our democracies
thank you if you could maybe comment on
uh
the difference quite a difference
between the usaid and ours uh but my
follow-up also is the the core ask of
president zielinski speech yesterday was
for canada and western allies to enforce
a no-fly zone over ukraine you've said
before we know that's something canada
is not interested in doing but was there
anything that mr zielinski said
yesterday in his powerful speech
that made you reconsider that position
this is a
an extraordinarily difficult issue
because we see
the the impact of the bombs and the
cruise missiles falling on hospitals on
schools on ukrainian civilians it is
heartbreaking to see these images every
day of vladimir putin's
violence
against innocents across ukraine
as a nato alliance we continue to look
at ways we can help support and protect
ukrainians
and continue
to prevent this war from expanding and
escalating elsewhere these are
heartbreaking decisions and choices that
we have to make and i can assure you
that nato is constantly talking about
what more we can do what solutions we
can bring
we'll highlight however that in the
early days of the conflict the
ukrainians were far more successful than
the russians expected at shooting down
russian aircraft
and we've seen an emphasis away from uh
aircraft flying into russian uh into
ukrainian space and more bombs and
cruise missiles launched from a distance
which is a challenge in terms of closing
the skies as well
we'll take the last question
good afternoon jamie with city tv
a russian company is
tunneling holes for the scarborough
subway through metrolinx
where
where he owns a 20 stake in that company
where do the sanctions against the
russians start and stop there's other
russian investors in canada should we
cancel the
the contract paid outrageous uh
penalties or should we continue dealing
with the russians
our focus on these crushing sanctions
that we're applying to the russian
economy to vladimir putin himself and to
all who've supported and enabled him
are on
on
getting at the people responsible for
this illegal
terrible war in ukraine
we are very carefully targeting uh those
oligarchs and leaders themselves
and uh whether it's the
scarborough uh subway or uh ibrah steel
uh in saskatchewan uh we're making sure
that the support and the work for
canadians who are doing important work
in building a stronger future ourselves
is not impacted our
sanctions are targeted specifically at
those oligarchs and those supporters of
putin's ability to benefit from for
example the hard work of canadian
workers
mr mr prime minister there's a second
question um
you work in
ontario our mass mandate's coming down
when are you going to wear a mask are
you going to wear a mask
i think all canadians are
pretty damn tired of two years of this
pandemic and eager to get back to normal
as much as possible
at the same time we've also seen
canadians be very thoughtful and very
careful throughout this pandemic
about being there for each other about
keeping our frontline workers from being
overwhelmed
about being there for our vulnerable
loved ones
i think everyone as
measures get eased the federal
government has eased some of the
measures at the at the borders uh just a
few weeks ago we're going to continue to
look at what more we can do
as measures are eased and adjusted
across the country canadians will of
course benefit from that but also i know
continue to keep in mind the choices
needed from context to context to keep
themselves and their loved ones safe uh
i'm no different i will be making
decisions on what i can do to get back
to normal as best as possible while at
the same time making sure that i'm doing
my part to keep people safe and
individual choices and autonomy informed
by science informed by public health
recommendations is i think something
that we all agree on
thank you that concludes today's press
conference mercy semifinals
[Music]
uh
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
you